hi my name is Giani I'm the CEO and
founder of the word mobile services
company established in 2009 and launched
earlier this year over this period I've
been I've been over the past few years
have been heavily involved in supporting
entrepreneurs across the region dubai by
ruth a man and cairo where I'm based and
I personally think that entrepreneurs
need to get a lot of support in the
coming period the whole region is
changing and we also understand that our
young entrepreneurs are the biggest
contributors to our growth our job
creation and our external and economic
value are that they're creating is
actually very important to our countries
so I hope to see the ecosystem being
developed in a much better way angel
investor networks venture capital funds
banking regulation that allows more
support to SMEs and entrepreneurs and
I'm sure they will be a big addition to
the entire region thank you